y convertir todo lo que vemos en un micrófono?
Esto es una idea un poco extraña,
así que trataré de ponerlo en perspectiva.
Los micrófonos tradicionales funcionan convirtiendo el movimiento
de un diafragma interno en una señal eléctrica,
y el diafragma está diseñado para moverse fácilmente con sonido
de manera que su movimiento se puede grabar e interpretar como sonido.
Pero el sonido hace que todos los objetos vibren.
Esas vibraciones son por norma demasiado sutiles y rápidas para que se vean.
¿Y si grabamos con una cámara de alta velocidad
y luego usamos el software para extraer pequeños movimientos
de nuestro video de alta velocidad,
y analizamos los movimientos para averiguar qué sonidos se han creado?
Nos permitiría convertir objetos visibles en micrófonos visuales a la distancia.
Así que lo intentamos,
y aquí está uno de nuestros experimentos,
donde tomamos esta planta en maceta de la derecha
y filmamos con una cámara de alta velocidad
mientras que un altavoz cercano reproducía este sonido.